[Music]
the moral consciousness cannot forego
happiness and leave this element out of
its absolute purpose the purpose which
is expressed as pure Duty essentially
implies this individual
self-consciousness individual conviction
and the knowledge of it constitute an
absolute element in morality this
element in the objectified purpose in
the fulfilled duty is the individual
consciousness that beholds itself is
realized in other words it is enjoyment
which is thus implied in the notion of
morality not indeed immediately in
morality regarded as sentiment or
disposition but only in the notion of
its actualization this however means
that enjoyment is also implied in
morality as disposition for this does
not remain disposition in contrast to
action but proceeds to act or to realize
itself thus the purpose expressed as the
whole with the consciousness of its
moments is that the fulfilled Duty is
just as much a moral action as a
realized individuality and that nature
the aspect of individuality and contrast
to the abstract purpose is one with this
purpose necessary as is the experience
of the disharmony of the two sides
because nature is free even so what is
essential is Duty alone and nature
contrasted with it is devoid of a self
that purpose in its entirety which the
harmony of the two constitutes contains
within it actuality itself it is at the
same time the thought of actuality the
harmony of morality and nature or since
nature comes into account only insofar
as consciousness experiences its unity
with it the harmony of morality and
happiness is thought of as something
that necessarily is that is it is
postulated for to say that something is
demanded means that something is thought
of in the in the form of being that is
not yet actual a necessity not of the
notion qua notion but of being but
necessity is at the same time
essentially relation based on the notion
the being that is
demanded then is not the imagine being
of a contingent consciousness but as
implied in the notion of morality itself
whose true content is the unity of the
pure and the individual consciousness it
is for the latter to see that this unity
be for it an actuality in the content of
the purpose this is happiness but in its
form its existence in general the
existence thus demanded that is the
unity of both is therefore not a wish
nor regarded as purpose one whose
attainment were still uncertain it is
rather a demand of reason or an
immediate certainty and presupposition
of reason
here in paragraph 602 we're seeing this
interplay between two sides both of
which are being held together by what
Hegel is called the moral consciousness
and the question that we're really
asking ourselves here is one that's
reversible I framed it as what does
morality really require from the moral
consciousness what is the demand that
morality is making upon the individual
person who is aware of their duties but
we can also say what demand does the
individual get to make in return upon
morality is there anything that the
moral consciousness gets to say about
the constraints that morality places
upon it or the way in which it valuates
things in the world that are not it and
so what are the two sides that are at
stake here one side is that of duty and
morality very much stresses duty whether
it be a Conchie enormities available at
the time even the hedonistic morality x'
were quite often framing things in terms
of a duty to yourself to assure yourself
of pleasure or something like that right
so duties on one side and then we have
this this realm of what Hegel
essentially following can't here
although as we've seen there there's
more to it than just the conscient
problematic what he's calling nature not
to her right and what's associated with
that again this is a very conscient
formulation happiness glueck daily kite
and we should talk a little bit about
this word because he --gel now is using
a term that's similar to but not exactly
the same as what has been called
happiness in the translation in the
previous paragraph that was glueck this
is glueck daily kite and you could say
this is almost kind of like eudaimonia
right it refers to a state of the spirit
or the
Sol and it's using that term glueck
happiness enjoyment pleasure you could
even say it's a state of the soul being
you you could say in in good condition
and you know it fits this notion of you
diamond ism because Kant had criticized
any you die monistic ethics as
essentially following our natural
impulses and giving in to to nature and
removing us from any genuine
relationship to morality to fulfilling
our duties for the sake of Duty he saw
freedom as lying solely on the side of
morality and duty to be in thrall to our
own desires for happiness whatever we
conceive of as happiness is in fact to
be unfree so all of that is sort of
background material now let's look at
the text Hegel says the moral
consciousness now notice what he says
here cannot forego happiness
it cannot leave that behind you might
say well why not I mean it knows that
Duty is duty and it's got nothing to do
with happiness this is the very
problematic that Hegel is going to
explore Conte is not the final word or
any day similarly deontological ethics
instead we have to find some way to
incorporate or at least address our
continual desire for happiness so he
says it cannot forego happiness and
leave this element out of its absolute
purpose the moral consciousness is
motivated by purpose by Beck and Zack
could be translated as end or goal so
there's a teleological structure here
right that is being explored within the
not just this passage but within this
entire section so he says the moral
consciousness cannot forego happiness
leave this element out of its absolute
purpose the purpose which is expressed
as pure duty the purpose is being
expressed in that way in that mode is
that really the totality of it he says
it essentially implies this individual
self-consciousness individual
self-consciousness not just general
self-consciousness every single
individual is bound by the same duties
not just generally but as the individual
who he or she happens to be and they're
bound thereby also to forego their
happiness and at the same time they
cannot do this
so he says individual conviction and the
knowledge of it constitute an absolute
element in morality that makes sense
right we're talking about a certain
stage in human development and again I
want to stress the difference between
what Hegel here calls morality or in
German morality and what he calls the
ethical you know that's it Lika which
was at a previous stage which could
involve the individual but might also be
seen as just what happens to be the case
in that community in that culture and
might be viewed more more generally less
individualistically so he goes on and he
says this element what's the element
individual conviction and the knowledge
of it this element in the objectified
purpose in the fulfilled duty is the
individual consciousness what that
beholds itself as realized so here's
where we have a problematic arising when
I am in fact doing my duty when I am
following out what it is
what does morality demand
me to recognize and to follow out my
duty not for the sake of happiness but
for the sake of that very duty
recognizing it as an absolute value that
is binding upon me just as it is binding
upon other people when I do that and I
realize that I wind up having a certain
kind of happiness I wind up realizing
what it is for me to be genuinely moral
and it's not just to have this idea of
duty and to try to live up to it it's to
realize it here Hegel's gonna go back
and forth between realization of the
individual and realization of the notion
the because right so he goes on and he
says in other words it is enjoyment
enjoyment what does that have to do with
duty what does that have to do with
morality we're gonna come back to that
which is thus implied he says in the
notion of morality enjoyment is implied
in the notion of morality doesn't that
just turn it into what we had just
called a kind of you diamond ISM be a
good boy and you get your reward or be a
good person and virtue will be its own
reward because virtue will feel good for
you or something like that it's not
quite going there but that should be in
the back of our mind so he says it's an
enjoyment which is implied in the notion
of morality now notice what he says next
it's implied not immediately but in
morality regarded as sentiment or
disposition but only in the notion of
its actualization so Hegel is setting
aside any sort of sentimentality any
sort of affective relation say that of
sympathy for example as a a motive for
for following our duty that's not what's
actually going to be providing us with
the enjoyment
nor as he says is it a matter of
disposition so a question you could ask
yourself here is is Hegel rejecting
earlier forms of virtue ethics or at
least the ways in which they were being
understood at the time is he rejecting
an ethics of sympathy as we find
developed in say Smith or Hume or later
and you know to some degree in
Schopenhauer is he rejecting these sorts
of things as having anything to do with
morality he's saying those aren't
actually going to get you to the notion
of morality because the notion of
morality requires that the individual as
he says here the notion of it's
actualization that's being made via
cleek it's being put there in the world
the duty becomes an action a honda m--
or taught a deed right so he goes on and
he says this means that enjoyment is
also implied in morality as disposition
why why can we recuperate disposition at
this point here again we see an
interesting move in some ways past con
people by the way will often only read
the groundwork for the metaphysics of
morals within which can't you know sets
out this very stark opposition between
duty and happiness or duty in nature the
free will in nature and they don't go on
to read the actual metaphysics of morals
in which Kant does in fact say that
dispositions are quite important to
cultivate in order not as a not as a
reliable way of every single time making
sure we do our duty that is something we
can go on autopilot with but as a kind
of support for what we need to do so he
goes on and says it does not remain
disposition in con
to action but proceeds to act or to
realize itself when we have a
disposition that that stems from duty
say a disposition towards the
benevolence or beneficence towards our
neighbors a disposition to truth-telling
one that steers us away from telling
lives when we actualize it when we are
realizing it in some sort of fulfillment
in in the kinds of actions that we
choose over and over and over again made
easier because we've got that almost
inertia moral inertia you could say that
has been established by the disposition
then it's no longer just a disposition
this is actually an interesting insight
that could in fact apply to many other
virtue ethics as well which are often
misread people say Aristotle says well
you just gotta establish a habit and
then you know you're gonna be a-ok
you'll be courageous when you need to be
courageous as if it's just you know
establishing a stimulus-response loop or
some sort of turning the the higher
faculties off rather than a way of
orienting and supporting them so Hegel
goes on and he says the purpose
expressed as the whole with the
consciousness of its moments is that the
fulfilled Duty is just as much a moral
action now here's a really interesting
thing the fulfilled Duty is just as much
a moral action as they realized
individuality a fulfill Duty is not just
an action it's not just checking
something off it's me the person who is
doing the duty I am the one who told the
truth I am the one who gave the fair
price I am the one who assisted the
person in need that becomes me this is
part of the moral perspective on the
self
so he goes on and he says here we go
that nature the aspect of individuality
and contrast to the abstract purpose the
duty is one with his purpose now we get
to an important transition point you
notice that we're thinking about whether
there's a harmony and Hegel's uses that
you know harmony between the the German
term harmony between nature and morality
or nature and duty or happiness and duty
so he says necessary as is the
experience of the disharmony of the two
sides because nature is free what's he
referring to in the earlier paragraphs
comprising this at the beginning of this
section we saw that both morality and
nature were free forms of freedom so how
could there be a relationship between
them that isn't you could say
antagonistic a harmony or some sort of
integration rather than a disharmony he
says even so what's essential is Duty
alone nature contrasted with it as
devoid of itself but the purpose in its
entirety which the harmony of the - he
says constitutes contains within it
actuality itself let's repeat that again
the purpose and its entirety the purpose
of moral consciousness that's Veck in
its entirety which the harmony of the
two constitutes how can it be an
entirety a whole a totality because
there is a harmony available in some
respect between these he says it's at
the same time the thought of actuality
now notice what he says next the harmony
of morality in nature or because nature
comes into account only as consciousness
it's unity with it now notice what terms
of uses next the harmony of morality and
happiness is thought of as something
that necessarily is and now here he says
it is postulated so Hegel is here
seemingly following in the footsteps of
Kant who had said something quite
similar but a bit different you know for
it to be postulated for Kant means that
we we have to kind of assume it we have
to think it we have to place literally
postulating as to place out there even
though we don't have evidence for it and
given the fact that we actually not only
don't have evidence we have counter
evidence for it so the harmony of
morality and happiness what would be we
be talking about there right if you're a
good boy you get a nice reward so what's
the nice reward well you know let's take
a short of religious point of view do
your duty and you'll go to heaven well
there might not be any heaven and that
doesn't really help you much in this one
okay do your duty and things will work
out for you be a nice person and people
will be nice to you know they might crap
on you they might kick you into the
ditch and treat you horribly you might
be stuck with in a world of nature that
not only has individuals doing mean
things to each other but has all sorts
of structural inequities as we talk
about them these days meaning ways in
which things have been you know going on
for a while that screw some people over
and benefit others including some who
don't fulfill their duties right
sometimes it's the bastards who seem to
enjoy the most happiness this is a real
problematic and there's you know one
classic way of dealing with is well
they're not really happy those people
who are enjoying power success Fame you
know pleasures getting to do whatever
they want whenever they want to owning
lots of slaves that's not real happiness
real happiness is something else
well that is true
that that's that that's quite correct
but it seems to tear this postulate
apart doesn't it what about other ways
of thinking about it that's what we're
going to get to next so let's go ahead
with this he says for to saying that
something is demanded
now notice what's doing the demanding at
this point right is it morality that's
demanding no it's the individual
conscious demanding something of
morality namely that it be compatible
with happiness to say that something is
demanded means that something is thought
of in the form of being that is not yet
actual not yet realized a necessity not
of the notion as notion but just a being
so he says but necessity is at the same
time essentially relation based on the
notion bit of hegelian metaphysics here
you know being not quite as good as
notion the being that is demanded is not
the imagined being of a contingent
consciousness but as implied he says in
the very notion of morality itself whose
true content is a unity a unity or a we
could say integration of what a unity he
says of the pure and individual
consciousness the individual
consciousness here being the one who is
desiring happiness the pure
consciousness being the realization of
Duty realization in the sense of
grasping it both of these are
consciousness that is being brought
together now at this point but this is
not yet actual is it so he goes on and
he says it's for the latter who's the
latter the individual consciousness the
individual moral consciousness it is for
the latter to see that this unity be for
it in actuality how does it see that
this unity be for it an actuality well
at some point it's going to require
making it an actual
isn't it right it can't just sit there
and think it otherwise it's just
dreaming it has to somehow make that be
the case so he says in the content of
the purpose this is happiness but in its
form is existence in general Hegel is
introducing a new wrinkle there isn't he
and its content its happiness in its
form existence in general it's very
being it's life so he says the existence
thus demanded the unity of both is
therefore not a wish not something just
idle regarded as purpose one whose
attainment were still uncertain he says
here it's a demand of reason or an
immediate certainty and presupposition
of reason it hasn't said how this is
actually going to be accomplished at
this point of course but it is saying
listen reason is requiring that in some
way all of these things be reconciled
with each other now one possibility for
this that we already explored in the
previous paragraph enjoyment fulfillment
were being referenced through here
enjoyment and fulfillment of what the
enjoyment of actually engaging in moral
action of being able to see oneself as a
moral being the fulfillment of one's
very I wouldn't want to use the word
nature here and in part because it's on
this side but the fulfillment of
something that is integral to human
being in its moral action that allows
say a higher level of happiness but this
is the two things that have to be said
here as we finish up thinking about this
paragraph one is this is not yet
realized and the second thing is it's
probably not going to turn out quite so
neat
as it appears to be for kind
justice at this point
you